first one remember what we call these
guys it's an equation but it has a
trigonal so we call it a trigonometric
equation you're solving it you want to
find values of x that make that work you
can't just put any values of X in your
life
you can't put 10 or 300 or etc if you do
those this light won't be true so we
want values where it is let's start with
the first slide we're looking for a base
angle a base angle 30 degrees is the
suggestion how do we find 30 degrees
where does that come from I heard the
word inverse inverse what okay so a cos
inverse so on your calculator you might
have posted that cos inverse of what
just read 3 on to just root 3 on see the
reason why we do that is because if you
want the base angle you want an acute
base angle and they always have a
positive in there does that give you 30
degrees thumbs up now just a quick view
I've been saying so far because I've
been deliberately giving you nice angles
right I've been saying so far if you can
remember it that's great but if not you
have a calculator okay let me give you a
tool to help you remember and it's
actually a tool we use to come up with
these in the first place beside where
you've done your working can you draw a
triangle for me like so and this
triangle is the one we used to actually
derive these results to begin with so
the angles in this triangle are 30 60
and 90 degrees okay so we call this the
30-60-90 triangle okay now if you could
remember a single trig ratio and I'm
going to give you the easiest one then
you can get all the rest of this
information without any other memory
okay the easy one to remember is this
sine 30 sine theta is the nicest one
it's a half no square roots there
nothing that's the easiest one you can
come up with and it's also very easy to
verify in your calculator if sine 30 is
1/2 which parasites to sign talk about
its opposite his opposite and here's
hypotenuse how did I know this song was
the opposite by the way
one yeah I'm talking about 30 degrees so
opposite goes down so opposite on
hypotenuse apparently is one on two one
on two right that's what's sine of 30 is
actually telling you opposite hypotenuse
is that relationship pythagoras will
tell you that the last side is root 3 so
this 30-60-90 triangle back when i was
in year ten eleven twelve the first
thing i would do as soon as i get a test
is i would draw that triangle i wouldn't
even know what question was coming up
but i'd expect eventually i would have
to use it okay at least once sometimes
multiple times because we like using
these angles so if you draw that guy can
you see now how I know that cause thirty
thirty degrees rather is the angle that
gives me that where's Route three it's
here too it's adjacent to thirty and
here's the hypotenuse which is - okay
this takes time to get used to but it's
a very handy tool once you do get used
to it
so if 30 degrees looks great the next
slide talks about the sine of cos how do
I know it's negative where am I looking
to find that out
yeah I'm looking in that first line then
there's a minus sign there so that means
negative when cos x is negative you
might like to draw a little diagram here
or maybe you already have why is it
quarter of two and three I'm looking for
cause to be negative clearly you can see
causes positive over here you see that
so those are duds I want this one to and
this one three so that's fantastic as
well then we have to work out well what
does thirty degrees look like in those
quadrants one fifty
how do we come up with that angle 180
takeaway very good and then what about
210 180 plus got it now that I'm gonna
lock it because it just keeps doing that
okay
ah looks good if there's a Judy student
I apologize
before we dig into the working do you
guys agree with these answers do you
agree
yeah they look okay so I will point out
just something with this the answer is
right I'm very happy with it however it
might have been a teeny bit easier if
this first slide was written upside down
like this now was it Leo did you do this
one Leo now Leo got the right answer
that's because this line of this slide
they have all the same information in
them it's all words the same triangles
but why is this just a teeny bit easier
why is it here yeah that's exactly right
all I have to do to get to a is multiply
by sine 60 which is a bit simpler to do
you'll get the same answer either way
I'm happy with that forty two point
seven degrees I'm okay with that but
usually angles aren't rounded off two
decimal places usually how would we
normally around them minutes right or
degrees if it was to the nearest degree
what would our answer be forty-three
that would be to the nearest degree if
we wanted to the nearest minute it would
be 42 degrees and how many minutes can
you press the button what do you get 41
42 that's a coincidence I just made up
those numbers so there you go